[موسيقى]
قد لا تقدم بنتلي
التحسينات المطلقة لسيارة رولز
رويس مثل سرعة بوجاتي أو التعامل مع
فيراري بدلاً من ذلك ، توفر بنتلي
التوازن مع الفخامة من ناحية
والأداء من ناحية أخرى ، مما يحقق
التوازن المثالي للسرعة والراحة.
فعلته القليل من العلامات التجارية بشكل رائع تمامًا
إذا كانت هناك سيارة تحدد
هوية بنتلي ، فيجب أن تكون كونتيننتال جي تي
، سيارة سياحية كبيرة قوية ومُحسّنة ، فهي
تنافس طرازات من أستون
مارتن وحتى أفضل سيارات
مرسيدس بنز ولكن عندما تكون كذلك
تجدها في الداخل كشخصية بنتلي مميزة
بالنسبة لها
، فأنا أتحدث عن أشياء مثل
الجلود المطرزة والمعدن
الأصلي والخشب وهذه الحيلة الأنيقة
التي إذا لم يكن هناك شيء آخر بمثابة خدعة أنيقة
لسيارة
سريعة وحديثة في نفس الوقت  نظرًا لأن أي سيارة في
فئتها
[موسيقى]
كونتيننتال جي تي هي بوضوح سيارة سياحية ،
فهي ليست مصممة لإثارة المفصل الأبيض ،
فهي تتمتع بوضع رياضي ولكن
بصراحة تشعر أنها في أفضل حالاتها في
إن وضع mal D for Bentley موجود
ولكن بالطبع حتى بين السيارات التي
تُعرّف على أنها سيارات سياحية كبيرة ، هناك
نطاق لمدى الإثارة التي
تجلبها السيارة إلى الطريق على الرغم من محركها الكبير
المكون من 12 أسطوانة وقوة كبيرة ،
تميل كونتيننتال بالتأكيد أكثر نحو السيارات
غير الرسمية  كروزر نهاية
الطيف وهنا حيث أجد أن بنتلي كان من الممكن
أن تمنح المزيد من المتعة
والاستجابة لسيارة كونتيننتال ،
قد ترتدي هذه السيارة سترة تدخين
ولكن هذا لا يعني أنها يجب أن تكون
مريحة طوال
الوقت  بنتلي كونتيننتال جي تي
بالقوة والأناقة سترضي أولئك الذين
يبحثون عن الاسترخاء الأنيق بأي
سرعة
[موسيقى]